i know that there are at least two or
three deleted scenes that will be
included in the multiverse anything is
possible the ending of doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness that we saw
isn't the only one that exists let's
check out just how different all the
multiverse possibilities were oh and
before you watch any further this is
your warning there are spoilers ahead
you always suspected this day would come
i'm ready number one
to be fair doctor strange did have a
pretty significant impact on
spider-man's last movie you know with
the whole spell and all that
one of the biggest ways that this film
changed was due to the impact of it
coming after no way home instead of
before as it was originally slated to it
wasn't until no way home was actually
completely finalized that the second
doctor strange film could really be
nailed down this reorder in the phase 4
of the mcu had a major impact but it was
for the best considering how great both
films turned out to be in the end number
two
let's just say everyone was on their
toes for pretty much the whole
production
you okay the team behind multiverse of
madness actually completed half of their
filming days before an ending had even
been established these actors have
learned to have faith in the creative
team who managed to make this chaotic
world and story makes sense to the
audiences when that ending was shared it
was best that no one got their hopes up
since the conclusion of the film did
change a few more times after that they
did do extensive reshoots after all but
more on that soon number three can you
say bonus features our fingers are
crossed that we'll get a solid chunk of
deleted footage when the doctor strange
two special features are released
especially since we got way less than
expected for no way home what's
particularly exciting about the deleted
footage we know of is that it comprised
almost a full third of what the final
film was supposed to be sam raimi's
first cat came in around 2 hours and 40
minutes
it was probably like 2 hours and 40
minutes
and it slowly came down
even though we did the reshoots we were
just this close to seeing another 30
minutes worth of all this brilliant
madness
raimi has teased that there's one in
particular he's really hoping gets
released so fingers crossed this is the
only way
number four it would have been an
intense start that's for sure this movie
was supposed to begin on a very
upsetting note there was actually a
version that saw mordo going after wanda
with a magical bow
and he was there to take her down
despite his attempts though wanda came
out victorious like the boss she is
in the end the team went in a different
direction and there are a few reasons
they could have done this but one of the
more obvious ones is that this might
have been a bit too similar in vibe to
what happened in the first doctor
strange remember that why are you doing
this
because i see at long last what's wrong
with the world
too many sorcerers plus with the secret
of the role the scarlet witch plays in
this one being kept that much longer it
really does up the stakes number five
multiverses makes for multi characters
and it could get hectic rachel mcadams
got more screen time in this film than
she did her first time around and part
of that was because we got to see two
great versions of christine palmer
however what we didn't get to see was
the third version of the character that
was written into the script once upon a
time now that the multiverse has been
cracked wide open though maybe we'll
meet another palmer in the mcu future
we wouldn't hate it number six when
reshoots came along so did multiple
extra characters the illuminati will see
you stephen spider-man no way home might
just have one of the most stacked cameo
lists out there and since it was such a
success the multiverse of madness
production team decided to follow in
their footsteps and they wrote in as
many cool and unexpected cameos as they
could and are we ever glad they did that
being said they did always make sure it
was what was best for the story and
would best serve the fans anything is
possible in the multiverse so why not
take advantage of that fact the og
scripts didn't include mr fantastic or
black bolt balder the brave was also a
possibility but ultimately didn't make
the final cut we took out material even
though the reshoots went in number seven
where did the lines go we have to admit
we were pretty disappointed to not get a
few moments featured in the promo
footage especially wanda's devilish line
this is going to be fun lizzie wilson
did get a version of a line we
anticipated coming from strange though
every night
i dreamed the same dream
and then
the nightmare begins
and we can't forget this beat featuring
wong hanging out with the nosy cave but
to be fair that shot was never meant for
this film since it actually came from a
promo for a laundry detergent the stakes
are real he's literally coming up
against versions of himself number eight
it's strange like we have never seen him
before
trailer footage and promo material gave
us this line from sinister strange
things just got out of here
but the movie it gave us nada this
moment could have been an alternate
version of a scene or potentially an
extended cut while it is a pretty
stellar moment short as it is ultimately
it wasn't missed in the movie but we are
glad it was used in the promo footage
cause it's fire number nine we love a
throwback fans of the animated x-men
show from the 90s should be familiar
with professor x and his hover chair
there was an even longer battle planned
for the plot than what we got to see at
least from what's seen in the
pre-visuals can anyone say bonus
features
a battle this good only comes along so
often
number 10
we've got some questions
so before the final cut was established
there was a world where we did get the
khmartaj battle except it happened quite
a bit later in the movie that big of a
battle so early on might have been
intense and wound up fitting where it
does well another moment that leaves us
a bit puzzled is when wanda seems to be
facing her end after destroying the
darkhold castle but there was a chance
that we were going to see her beneath
the rubble afterwards without it it does
feel like that was the end of the
scarlet witch but
wanda could still have a chance and if
not this wanda then may be a variant at
some point in the future number 11. this
was one of the earliest bumps in the
road for this production once upon a
time when scott derrickson was directing
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness the movie had some very
different vibes the director had a
vision for the story and how it should
come to the screen but ultimately it
wasn't in line with what the marvel team
wanted and derekson wasn't gonna budge
marvel did end up making some requests
for changes to sam raimi's version but
it was always only ever for the sake of
the mcu and continuity in the multiverse
no this is what happened in the last
avengers movie and this is contrary to
that we have to be on the same page
number 12
we've got to talk about this
what about that crow this one we got
images of this random crow and promo
material but when the movie came along
nothing who is it what's its purpose
if anyone has theories about this crow
hit us up in the comments
now that is quite the roller coaster it
was far from easy to work through the
constant changes but this team is used
to it by now and made the best of what
they had which alternate or deleted
scene would you like to see and if
anyone knows what's up with that crow
hook us up